Speaker 1: Hey, here's a caller who is trying
to make me feel shame about the size of my
subscriber base.
Two one nine two David Pakman is the number.
Take a listen to this.
Speaker 7: Hey, Dave, your show is so pathetic,
970 subscribers.
Speaker 1: Now, this is not a Boston accent
is a Rhode Island accent.
It's sort of like the Boston accents.
A little brother important to distinguish
just from the standpoint of geography.
But what does this 970 subscribers?
What's he talking about?
Speaker 7: My God, I don't know how you get
the balls to be so fucking stupid.
The balls.
Yeah.
You got more subscribers invited by this guy
is unbelievable.
You suck so bad.
I'm only watching you because YouTube shut
them down.
Speaker 1: Anybody know what on earth that
guy is talking about?
900 subscribers.
We have over 9000.
We actually we have one point.
What do we have one point three, one point
four million on YouTube.
Anyway, that's our friend from Rhode Island.
Appreciate you tuning in.
We've got a great bonus show today.
We'll talk about rent prices soaring as people
are going back to cities.
We'll talk about a safe consumption site,
the first in the US.
And a really unusual decision by a court relating
to FDA approval.
All of those stories and more on today's bonus
show.
Get instant access by becoming a member at
Join Pakman dot com.